hi i'm mercedes and today i'm going to
show you a little bit about what i do to
live a healthier lifestyle about three
years ago i realized that i was not
living a healthy lifestyle at all i
barely cooked for myself i ate takeout
way too often so i decided to make a
change by doing so i just started making
recipes that were healthy and i started
meal prepping i love to work out in the
morning it boosts my day it gives me
energy and so i needed a meal that was
gonna last to make me feel full during
my workout and even after my workout and
so i always make smoothies having
something that i could just make very
quickly that was already prepped in the
freezer pop it in the blender put it in
a mason jar and go meal prepping in
general is just something that has
helped me save time in the long run
because that's the issue i think with
living a healthy lifestyle people get
intimidated because it's a lot of time
and effort but if you have your meals
made you don't have to think about it
it's there it's made you get to eat
healthy make healthy choices you save
money my body functions so much better
eating healthy when i first started on
my fitness journey i did a lot of
at-home programs because i was
definitely very intimidated by the gym
in the comfort of my home i got a bunch
of equipment and i did a lot of things
there and there's a favorite routine
that i love to do and i actually made a
video about it
and it's to relieve those tight hips
that you get when you do running because
running can be very harsh on your hips
and your calves so this was specifically
something that i love to do and so i
wanted to share it with others so the
video is for people who are just
starting out yoga and don't really know
much about it it's for beginners and
people who are new to the whole world of
yoga but it also offers a little bit of
moves for more advanced people so it's
definitely a generalized video it's for
everybody and it's very very simple move
so that even if you are advanced it's
still important that you do these to
have good technique when i first started
working out i think the visual aspect is
what's really important because a lot of
times you don't know if you're doing the
moves correctly so i really wanted to
make a video that would allow people to
see what the moves need to be and where
you need to be stretching certain parts
of your body a lot of the struggles that
i had with working out was like finding
a program that was suited for me and
also just making sure that i was doing
stuff right i would constantly have to
look up videos or like youtube things to
just see if i was doing the form right
and i think that was the biggest thing
is how do i know if this workout is
gonna like give me the results that i
want and i just kind of had to trust
myself and just keep learning and i've
done a lot of different programs but i
think weight lifting gets you the
results that you want faster and it's
not as intimidating as you think i think
if you actually go there and just allow
yourself to do it and not care what
other people think it's totally
worthwhile and it's a quality workout
and i think a lot of times it's easier
almost than working out like cardio
excessively or just like at home and
also you're just surrounded by people
who inspire you and that's what i love
one of the biggest things that i would
recommend is making snack boxes if
you're anything like me you will give
into temptation and snack like crazy i'm
a big snacker i pack carrots and hummus
and vegetables things like that to make
sure that if i see something that i want
or if i'm like hungry and like i could
grab a bag of chips at work i will not
do that because i have my snacks super
super essential and when you're packing
snacks it's important to pack snacks
that have flavors that you like like
don't pack kale just because you think
it's healthy my favorite snack is
bananas and almond butter it's so simple
you just need a little container for
your almond butter and then a banana and
if you're good to go it has helped me so
much when there are so many things
around at work and i work next to tasty
people who are constantly making oh my
gosh the most delicious looking things
that i want to eat all the time and the
only way for me to be like
no is to know that i have put money time
effort into a pack that's already there
and i can go eat it and it's perfect
when i first started this health journey
it was really just about being able to
cook for myself and making healthier
dinners in general but then i started
getting really into finding healthier
alternatives for things because i found
myself still wanting pasta and things
like that so it was all about how can i
healthify certain meals and that's
really what i wanted to do because
that's the thing is you want to eat the
things that you are craving but you want
to make it healthy you want it to be
good for your body one thing that i did
for the garlic chicken pasta video is i
put kale in it because i like kale but i
noticed a lot of people actually don't
like kale and they really wanted spinach
in it but that's the great thing about
this is you can put whatever you want
into it doesn't have to be what i show
you in the recipe you can exchange the
veggies for whatever veggies you want
and things like that i just reached a
point in my life where i was tired of
feeling the way that i was feeling which
was just very
low energetic and depressed really i
dedicated my life to eating better
cooking for myself it is incredible to
see how far i've come i'm very proud of
myself and it's not it has not been a
perfect like progression of like point a
to point b i've gone like ups and downs
it's not perfect overall i'm proud of
the changes that i've made in my life
and i'm going to continue making changes
and continue to challenge myself because
that's what life is about i think the
best thing for me is that i get to share
all the things that i love with you and
i just hope that you love it too and it
inspires you to live a healthier
lifestyle
oh yes
how's that
to
yeah
[Music]